did he go up the fast lane yeah I'm just
talking to the next station right now
okay
sure do you know where this guy's at he
should be upstairs
all right I'm gonna go up to that exit
you guys stay here
um
[Music]
guy with lots of arm tattoos and beard
yes sir also I'll call Sandusky Police
can you stop over here please
I have one with me right now
okay
[Applause]
did you have any kind of disagreement
with somebody any kind of Confrontation
okay do you have an idea on you
yeah
go to Richmond County
um
yourself all right
already
items
here you know the traffic
[Music]
thank you
hello
you said you were not involved in any
kind of altercation downstairs
[Applause]
whatever happened down there I mean I
wasn't there to see it but yeah listen
um but if uh if Richardson County
doesn't want you you're gonna have to
speak for security
um
so so we're we're waiting to hear back
on a possible hornhead
um are you gonna 27 in the morning
[Music]
I'll call
um yeah
I have I have my mind on Sandusky so
good night
all right sir go ahead and play
something fun you're back for me okay
he's in custody are they going to come
get him or do they want to relay
[Music]
I'm just gonna double lock these so they
don't Tighten Up On You
[Applause]
okay
you're not gonna charge with anything
here this is just for your warrant
so you gotta warrant through Richland
County I don't know what it's for but
they want you so we got to play Santa
Claus today okay
yeah so somebody reported that they got
into some sort of confrontation with you
but they don't want to press charges so
it's over and done with you don't got to
worry about it
are you thinking
out
that way
add uh corporate
yeah yeah we can bring him over here
that way
Monroe and what part
601 West Madison okay
uh we don't know if they're rich in the
county
uh 2022.
0 .
go ahead
come around the Casey
's will be out
foreign
[Applause]
a possible drunk
no it said it's uh the warrant is
failure to appear for dangerous drugs
so you did you skip a court date no I'm
on papers okay then you can go tell the
judge about it I don't know man I'm not
from around there
foreign
go to Erie County and uh Richland county
is going to come get you tomorrow
because we're not driving all the way
down there so rich and Connie's gonna
come pick you up
dangerous drugs
foreign
that's four years old okay that that one
is so I never heard things you were
sentenced then oh yeah I've already
sentenced the cbcf okay
well I mean I'm sure they can get it
straightened out then but you still just
have to go talk to the judge about it
so with what's in the computer so
you got probation then or what now
they'll figure it out
yeah I mean we don't have the paperwork
but that's just what's up
um I'll see what Don wants to do yeah
all right
so I'll speak I'll speak to the
lieutenant when she gets back here with
the car and uh we'll see what we want to
do with that but if at a bare minimum
you'll be able to call somebody when you
get to the county okay now I shouldn't
have to go to a county dude you got a
warrant you're going to the county
period that's how it works
I don't know
please
Ariel
another city
right on a Raptor yeah
[Music]
um probably just have him pull up right
here in the driveway I don't need to
have them all the way in here
all right
go ahead and open it all the way up
face car please
[Music]
got anything on you beside your wallet
cigarettes
um
[Music]
it's about a Midway
um
sorry I don't know
his name is Wesley cross
sorry w-e-s-l-e-y
last name c-r-o-s-e
Hey Wesley
for you okay
you gonna season pass Wesley uh no uh
potato
Chan no sorry all right
yeah okay